yes sir welcome thank you first of all I
want to say congratulations to you sir
because you've it's been about a year
and some change year and a half since
you've been here yeah and I feel like
since then I mean you've always had a
huge presence on YouTube and like uh but
like I feel like your growth as a
personality has been is insane Mac eats
is on fire let's go Mac talk you know
what I'm saying twitch right that's the
that's the other channel okay that's the
channel
because you were also doing like uh
weren't you also doing like um
interviews yeah yeah yeah I'm doing it
now that's the night talk okay you're
right yeah yeah but hold up
congratulations to you though well thank
you man you know me I've been seeing you
no I've been seeing you leveling up like
you know what I'm saying like uh
congratulations to you and your new club
yeah man we got 11 11. new studio this
is probably the last interview anyone
will watch in the studio China mag makes
makes the eggs it you feel me it's only
right yeah
um but yeah dude it's been dope to see
dude because I always felt like that was
one thing when people would watch you on
Vlad
you know I feel like your your
personality would shine through and
people were so into you I mean you also
are an amazing rapper right but I feel
like people just kind of
um they took a liking to like just who
you are as a dude you know what I'm
saying so for you to be able to go
around and like tour different areas and
eat the food and like dude it's better
than any of the [__] food shows that
I told yo [__] no I mean like I do not
like food shows on Netflix [__] but your
[__] is lit it's a little different I
put a little spin on it like how would
like okay obviously you're always gonna
try to evolve and improve the show but
at what point in time do you feel like
you got to a place where the show felt
like fully like oh no this is like
things are different now when I started
going to the hoods and the food like
everybody does
like you know go to the popping
restaurants oh look this restaurant is
so cool but like when I started going
into people houses and they cooking out
the house and selling meals out there
like that I was like okay I'm wanting
something yeah I mean like because
people ain't gonna do that people ain't
gonna go into the middle of watts and
like you know I mean go to a house and
eat waffles with cereal on it or go in
Stockton in the middle of nowhere and
they cooking and crabs and stuff how was
Stockton Stockton's a pretty active
Place yeah Stockton is like yeah it's
definitely is active you know I mean I
had to be very it was kind of quiet but
it's one of those quiet that you know is
like is it get crazy you know what I'm
saying so for where all have you gone so
far like like in terms of just like
where's the craziest place you've gone
or the most random Place Stockton's kind
of random shout out to Stockton yeah
Stockton shout out to Stockton I'm at
the Texas
uh like Houston Dallas or I I mean I'm
going to Houston shout out to akiway I'm
about to go with them I'm about to go
Aggie way to Houston but no I went to
some
I don't even remember the name of the
town bro it was just like some random
spot that I I did I did a uh I did a
challenge like a steak challenge day or
something oh so it was like a restaurant
where they had like a famous yes I
pulled up over there and then like you
know but um I've been to uh Cambridge
Boston uh I've been to
um a bunch of places bro that I'd be
forgetting but yeah what's been the uh
worst Food you've eaten on on Macy's Wow
Wow just be honest
um Filipino food bro really yeah was
that in Stockton no that was right here
Kazumi brought me to the spot shout out
to her she's a she's a yeah she's a
professional yeah she is you like her I
mean I mean
she may or may not have popped up on a
friend of mine's Reddit feed not mine
yeah right
yo but um
yes she brought me to like eat some
Filipino food like some traditional not
traditional did you do the baby duck egg
yo that was you did that I did that oh
yeah that's what that's what yeah that
[__] is [__] shout out to my Philip I
mean everyone around me in my life is
Filipino is it are they my manager's
Filipino my producer for my radio Show's
Filipino most of my fight I got so many
Filipino shout out to the Philippines
that like uh yeah it's just you know I
mean it's like a half yeah half
developed baby right you see some of the
egg but then you see some of the the
it's like halfway developed
and you ate that
you know yeah it was gross it was Grosso
yeah it was it was just
it was just yeah it wasn't it wasn't my
thing